Suchen wir leicht an der falschen Stelle nach
außerirdischem Leben?
Und zwar nicht im Weltall, sondern nach der
falschen Art.
Diese These vertritt jetzt ein Astrobiologe
der Universität München.
Demnach gibt es Anzeichen, dass das erste
Leben nicht zellulär war, also aus Zellen
bestand, sondern Viren waren.
Sie gelten heute gar nicht als Leben, weil
sie ohne einen Wirt nicht überleben können.
Aber vielleicht war das ja mal anders.
Und wenn dem so ist, so Aleksandar Janjic,
dann suchen wir auf dem Mars mit den falschen
Geräten.
Clixoom Science & Fiction Hier gibt es täglich
spektakuläre Science Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal.
Nur dann verpasst ihr kein Video.
Herzlich willkommen
Wir hatten ja hier letztens über Riesenviren
berichtet, die etwas, ja fast beängstigendes
in sich tragen.
Ihr Genom enthält überraschenderweise auch
die Bauanleitungen für die Proteinbiosynthese.
Und das ist bei den Tupanviren der Fall.
Ein Forschungsteam aus Frankreich hatte Proben
aus einem alkalischen Salzsee in Brasilien
und ebenso aus der Tiefsee vor der brasilianischen
Atlantikküste entnommen und dabei diese Riesenviren
aufgespürt.
Sie hatten Amöben befallen, die ihnen als
Wirt dienten.
Die Analyse unter dem Elektronenmikroskop
enttarnte dann ihre enorme Größe und “den
längsten Schwanz, der je bei einem Virus
beschrieben wurde”, so einer der beteiligten
Forscher, Jonatas Abrahão.
Das wirklich Außergewöhnliche an diesem
Virustyp ist sein Genom.
Denn das enthält die Bauanleitung für den
gesamten Prozess der Proteinbiosynthese.
Und das ist wirklich ein Novum in der Biologie.
Ein Organismus gilt nur dann als Lebewesen,
wenn er sich selbst vermehren kann.
Konkret passiert das durch die sogenannte
Proteinbiosynthese, bei der - vereinfacht
gesagt - in Zellen neue Eiweiße gebildet
werden.
Bisher war klar: Dazu sind höhere Organismen,
aber auch Pilze und Bakterien, in der Lage.
Viren dagegen brauchen Wirtszellen, um sich
zu vermehren.
Denn sie selbst besitzen weder die Gene noch
die Ausstattung, um Proteine selbstständig
herzustellen.
Und so gelten Viren eben auch NICHT als echte
Lebewesen!
Bisher… Und genau das ist vielleicht der
Fehler, der unsere Sicht verengt und eine
zu enge Definition von Leben bewirkt.
Aber genau diese Sicht scheint isch jetzt
zu erweitern.
Denn Forschungsteams haben in den vergangenen
Jahren schon mehrmals neue Viren entdeckt,
die sich nicht an dieses Schema halten.
Dazu zählen beispielsweise die Riesenviren
namens Megavirus, Klosneuviren oder Panoravirus.
Allesamt sind genauso groß wie Bakterien
und ihr Erbgut ist ausgestattet mit viel mehr
Genen als man es bislang von Viren kannte.
Konkret enthält die DNA der Tupanviren bis
zu 1,5 Millionen Basenpaare und bis zu 1425
Gene, die Proteine kodieren.
Damit ist es das viertgrößte Genom eines
Virus’, das bislang bekannt ist.
Sie enthalten die Bauanleitungen für Enzyme,
die alle 20 Aminosäuren bauen können und
bis zu 70 Transport-RNAs.
Alles unabdingbare Faktoren für die Prozesse
der Proteinbiosynthese und damit ihrer eigenständigen
Vermehrung.
Und das alles ist auch für die Forschungsteams
eine große Überraschung.
Denn all das zusammengezählt, ähneln sie
sehr den echten zellulären Organismen!
Nur eine Sache fehlt und das sind die sogenannten
Ribosomen.
Diese zellulären Gebilde treiben die Proteinbiosynthese
an; Aleksandar Janjic sagt jetzt, wenn wir
das nicht berücksichtigen, dann übersehen
wir vielleicht die ersten Lebensformen auf
dem Mars.
Denn wenn das alles zutrifft, könnten die
Viren nicht nur echtes Leben sein, sondern
dann vielleicht sogar das erste Leben auf
der Erde.
Bam!
Doch die ExoMars Mission ist gar nicht dafür
eingerichtet in proben Viren zu erkennen.
Zur Zeit sei lediglich geplant, so Janjic,
zelluläre Fossilien, bioindizierte Sedimentstrukturen,
zum Beispiel Ausscheidungen oder konservierte
organische Verbindungen in zwei Metern Tiefe
aufzuspüren.
Die Astrobiologie geht davon aus, dass der
Mars etwa bis 500 Millionen Jahre nach der
Planetenbildung lebensfreundlich war.
In einem für die Evolution relativ kurzen
Zeitraum könnte es aber nun sein, dass sich
eben nur Viren gebildet haben.
Mit den bisherigen Messmethoden wären sie
nicht auffindbar.
Sein Vorschlag deshalb: Baldmöglichst, vielleicht
schon bei der Exomarsmission, Mikroskopiergeräte
mit an Bord zu nehmen, die Viren im Marsstaub
aufspüren können.
Und wenn sie die dann finden würden und zwar
nur Spuren von Viren, wären die Konsequenzen
revolutionär.
Dann wäre es tatsächlich so, dass Viren
die erste Entwicklungsstufe des Lebens waren.
Wow.
Wir halten euch dazu natürlich auf dem Laufenden.
Und genau zu diesem Thema: Außerirdische
machen wir unseren 10 Jahre Jubiläums, 500tausend
Abonennten-Spezailstream. am Donnerstag, den
13.
Dezember.
Hier könnt’ ihr ihn schonmal vormerken.
Stellt uns gerne jetzt schon eure Fragen zu
diesem Thema, die wir dann im Stream beantworten
können!
Gerne auf WhatsApp, der Link ist hier.
Ich freue mich auf viele Fragen und natürlich
euch im Livestream.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!